[Music]
a convicted criminal pleaded guilty to
murdering two maryland sisters who
vanished more than 40 years ago Sheila
and Kathryn Lyon were 12 and 10 years
old when they disappeared from a
shopping mall in 1975 the mystery
rattled the region and sent fear through
the community Lloyd Lee Welch
a former carnival worker will likely
spend the rest of his life behind bars
for their murders chip Reid is at the
Wheaton mall in Maryland where the girls
were last seen decades ago many people
remember this story forty years later
chip good morning well good morning it
was just an ordinary day forty-two years
ago when those two young girls walked
from their nearby home to this small
their mother told them be home by 4:00
p.m. but they never returned and for
many people in this community their
disappearance is still a painful memory
investigators canvassed neighborhoods by
air and on the ground after 10 year old
Catherine and 12 year-old Sheila
disappeared but leads turned into dead
ends and the case went cold there's a
very tough case because the girls were
never found there was no crime scene
there was no there was no forensic
evidence
captain Darren Frank leads Montgomery
County's Major Crimes Division he said
many officers in his unit were haunted
by the case so 4 years ago they took a
fresh look you start saying wait a
minute there's something here there's
something here and then finding that
connection they discovered a composite
sketch of a man with long hair detailed
by a witness who claimed this person was
staring at the girls that sketch matched
a mug shot of Lloyd Welch police records
showed Welch came into the police
station shortly after the girls
disappeared and offered misleading
information officers discounted him and
thought he was trying to get the reward
money forty years later Welch was in a
Delaware jail convicted of sexually
assaulting a ten-year-old girl detective
mark Janney with the cold-case unit
spent more than a hundred hours
interrogating the man he calls a monster
he has no compassion no humanity and
he's right where he needs to be
Welch confessed he lured the two sisters
into a vehicle and witnessed someone
sexually assault one and murder
Catherine he said he then brought
Catherine's body to Bedford Virginia
where his family had property
on tuesday welch pled guilty in bedford
to two counts of first-degree murder but
investigators say he never admitted to
killing the girls and did not act alone
the final resting place of Sheila is
still unknown the Lyon family offered
their thanks to the unit they have
treated Sheila and Kate as if they were
their own sisters or daughters welch who
is 60 years old was sentenced to 48
years behind bars now investigators say
they have a file full of the names of
people who they believe knows something
about this case and they hope that
eventually someone will come forward and
tell them the whole truth Gayle yeah you
still after all this time I remember
that story guys because I was working at
a DC station at the time and at the time
it was so shocking because you didn't
hear about child abductions that way and
you see her little glasses and her
little sister and back then you would
always let your kids walk to the mall
and walk to the store totally changed
how everybody behaved back in that day
only imagine it physically makes me sick
I remember that story very vividly thank
you very much too